في اغنيه اسمها اعز الناس قالت ليلى علوي
او عفوا ليلى مراد فيها مش عملتها مغنيه
ليلى علوي طبعا الفنانه القديره الله
يرحمها ليلى مراد قالت دلي مالوش حبيب ما
تشوف عيون ضي يقضي عمره غريب للوطن ولا حي
ولا حي هذا الشعور الشعور بالوحده اخطر
مما تتخيل وصراع على البقاء على قيد
الحياه جراحها امريكي يحذر ان الشعور
بالوحده مضره على صحه وجسد الانسان مثل
التدخين خمسه عشره سيجاره في اليوم الواحد
وهو طبعا مشاهدينا مرتبط بزياده مخاطر
الاصابه بامراض القلب والاوعيه الدمويه
والخرف ايضا واكيد الاكتئاب وقد تزيد ايضا
من خطر الوفاه المبكره بنسبه 30% الدكتور
ريفيك مورثي قال ان بلاده تواجه وباء
الوحده والعزله واستند على احدى دراسات
التي وجدت ان حوالي نصف البالغين من
الامريكيين يعانون من الوحده
دكتور
قال ايضا ان زياده العزله الاجتماعيه يجب
التعامل معها على انها تهديد للصحه العامه
مثل السمنه او
تعاطي المخدرات العاده
[موسيقى]
وللمزيد مشاهدينا نرحب بضيفتنا في
الاستوديو دكتوره منار ريحانه دكتوره
نفسيه ومعالجه اسريه اذا اهلا بك دكتوره
معنا
يعطيك العافيه صباح
الخير
وحالته الصحيه الجسديه وطبعا يمكن الخبر
اللي معنا اليوم عن موضوع الوحده
بانه بعاده تدخين 15 سيجاره بالنهار شاهد
على ذلك ولكن كيف ممكن بالفعل حالتنا
النفسيه اللي هي اشي بيعتمد على الافكار
وعلى المشاعر ممكن تاثر بشكل حسي على
جسمنا في البدايه صباح الايجابيه صباح
الوجوه الطيبه صباح العلاقات الاجتماعيه
الحلوه هلا كتير نحنا عم نتجلى هلا انت
حكيتي كلمه الوحده
والعزله قبل ما نبدا فيها راح احكي لك انه
معروف انه المرض
النفسي يسبق المرض الجسمي هلا انت لما
نحكي نحن عن الوحده في عنا عزله العزله في
ارادتنا نحن نختار انه ننعزل لفترات مؤقته
اذا نحن في عالم الايجابيه لا تعتبر سلبيه
اذا طورت الامور وصلنا لمرحله الوحده لسه
بكون التدخين قهوه واسهل في علاجه نقصد
العزله الغير اراديه اللي احنا يعني اقوى
هي يعني العزله بالضبط عندك وحده الوحده
هي مرحله متطوره عن العزله لان العزله هي
قلت لك ممكن تكون ايجابي انه نحن اخترنا
لوقت محدد لايام مثلا انا بدي اخذ قسط من
الراحه اجد نفسي فيها ارتب اوراقي لكن
الوحده هي خلاص انت فصلتي فعالم ثاني
ترتيب النفس لمواجهه المستقبل العزل ولي
العهد
قبل يعني ايضا بانه هل ما ينطبق على
المجتمع الغربي ينطبق علينا ام انه الجيل
الجديد اصبح اقرب الى مثلا مجتمع الامريكي
بانه هو منعزل على الاقل بايراد الان
فتتطور مع عائله وحده طبعا هلا مجرد ما
انت دخلت خاصه فتره المراهقه او فتره
الشباب هلا اي نظريه اي نظريه موجوده في
العالم الخارجي هي بتنطبق بس ليس
بمقاييسنا نحن لانه النسب هناك اكبر هلا
لاحظ انه على الانتحار في دول اوروبا في
امريكا اكثر نتيجه ايش العزله اصلا اريد
هو مرض منتهي مرض نفسي عزله اكتئاب قلق
توتر انتهينا ممكن يوصل انت عم تحكي عن
التدخين هو اخطر انه هو ممكن يوصل
للانتحاد
بيدخنوا باكيتين وقاعدين مع الناس
ممكن الشخص على فكره اللي عم يشعر في
العزله موجود اصلا مع الاشخاص او الوحده
موجود مع
الوحده يعني ممكن تكون اخطر تدخيل
150 السجائر راح يؤدي الى تصلب الشرايين
الى امراض صدريه امراض في القلب طب كيف
الوحده بدها تعمل نفس العمل
بينما احنا مش عم بندخل اشي سيء او سامع
بالعكس نحن بندخل اخطر من السام هلا انت
عم تستخدمي التدخين التدخين حسب انت طبيعه
الجسم اللي موجوده عندك بينما الوحده انت
عم تشتغلي في مرحله الدماغ انت حطيتي كل
الانسان اللي بيدخل في الوحده راح يدخل في
اكتئاب الاكتئاب له يعني تخيل مثلا او كذا
مش الكورتيزون انت اصلا اقنعت نفسي دائما
نحن بنحكي العقل الباطني هلا اذا بدك انت
شيء لازم انا اشغل عندي العقل الباطني على
اني انا احصل عليه ما بصير اقول انا فاشل
ليش بدل انا كلمه انا فاشل نحن بنحكي
الافكار اللي عقلانيه اريد الانسان اللي
عم بيشعر في الوحده افكاره غير عقلانيه
غير سويه فانا دغري مباشره بحاول الانسان
اللي بدخل شوف الفرق في العزله ممكن انه
يستبدل الافكار اللا عقلانيه في الافكار
العقلانيه اني انا استبدل بدل ما انا احكي
انا مش رح اكل اليوم حلو انا بدي اعمل
دايت انا مش رح اكل حلويات اريد العقل
الباطني عندك عم يذكر الحلوات تلقائيا رح
تلاقيه امامك بينما انا احط انه لا انا
راح احاول اني انا اوكل السرطان تلقائيا
راح تشوف حالك انت رايح في اتجاه معناته
المرض النفسي يسبق المرض يعني دائما ما
يقال بانه لم يطب لك المقام بارضا فارتحل
ولكن العزله المؤقته كما تقولين هي
الايجابيه لكن الوحده هي مرحله متقدمه
شكرا دكتوره منال ريحنا دكتوره نفسيه
ومعالجه نفسيه يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك
يعطيك العافيه لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والت قارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك
في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات